Senpai, let's just give it up and have a fortune teller
Eh,
resisting is a waste of time, and it's going
to be a nuisance to the people waiting in line, so I
said yes.
After all, we don't sell it, so it
's not something that determines an individual's decision, and
it's up to the feelings of the person in question
.
It's the
first time for such a perfect couple This card shows that the two of
you are in a good mood This
card shows mutual trust This card shows your future stability
This one is the best cup
Come on, I heard that Ahana-chan and Senpai-
san aren't dating
.
I thought, well, I'm sure
the people standing in line must have
seen
it that way too.
firmly
[music]